Hilary Clinton has a ton of people
furious with her and for good reason
because she said nobody likes Bernie
Sanders now I'm gonna give you the
context I'm gonna give you the reaction
the analysis everything but notice that
it's all happening faster and faster now
the attacks on Bernie Sanders and and
now I'm going to take a position that
might shock you here I think it might be
true that Bernie Sanders is not the most
well-liked guy by his colleagues but I
don't think it matters one damn bit and
that's exactly what I want to talk about
today
there was an upcoming documentary it's a
series called Hillary and in the series
Hillary Clinton is asked about Bernie
Sanders and as first reported by The
Hollywood Reporter and since widely
widely corroborated including by Hillary
Clinton Hillary Clinton said quote he
was in Congress for years he had one
senator support him nobody likes him
nobody wants to work with him he got
nothing done he was a career politician
it's all just baloney and I feel so bad
that people got sucked into it now of
course the immediate question before we
get into the the lack of the
irresponsibility of this was is Hillary
saying that if Bernie is the nominee she
would not support Bernie over Donald
Trump her answer when she was recently
asked about it was quote I'm not gonna
go there yet we're still in a very
vigorous primary season I will say
however that it's not only him it's the
culture around him it's his leadership
team it's his prominent supporters it's
his on line Bernie bros and their
relentless attacks on lots of his
competitors particularly the women this
is how we lose okay there's a whole
bunch of analyses that we could do this
is how we lose once again this is the
top level analysis this is the type of
division that I'm talking about this
applies to Hillary doing it to Bernie
this applies to people saying I wouldn't
vote vote Biden no matter what I to
people attacking Warren and saying if
it's Warren over Bernie
I don't want Warren because
you voted in favor of more funding for
the military it applies to all of it
okay this is how we lose and we can talk
about the specifics of what being said
here and and here's my take I think it's
probably true that bernie is not the
most well-liked guy within the House and
Senate I've spoken to people who have
traveled with Bernie quite a bit in a in
a formal role and they've said he's
difficult when it comes to his
relationships with the House and Senate
he's not that well like who cares okay
what matters are two things what are
Bernie's policies who cares
if Joe Manchin doesn't like Bernie if
Bernie is going to fix health care okay
but I don't care do you care why does
Hillary care what matters is is what
Hillary Clinton is doing going to help
remove Donald Trump or not it's not it's
going to help reelect Donald Trump and
number two Bernie's policy what would he
do for people without health care the
same thing for Elizabeth Warren or for
Joe Biden or whatever are they better
than Donald Trump the answer is yes are
we taking actions that will make it more
likely that Donald Trump gets reelected
if the answer is yes don't do it okay
that's the test
Bernie by the way all but admits this
about himself what I mean is if you
watch the video so the New York Times
recently endorsed Amy Klobuchar and
Elizabeth Warren and they filmed a bunch
of interviews where they met with the
candidates and when they put out a video
from their conversation with Bernie
Sanders they asked Bernie about his
weaknesses and Bernie says I'm not the
guy this is my paraphrasing I'm not the
guy you Hobnobs I'm not the guy who I
think Bernie said who's gonna call you
on your birthday he's not socially a
pleasure to be around is what Bernie
Sanders is saying and this is very
similar to what Hillary Clinton is
saying he was not well liked by people
in the House and Senate it's probably
true but it's irrelevant and it's
embarrassing for Hillary Clinton to be
pulling it out now and to be playing coy
about whether she'd support Bernie if
he's the nominee it's not too soon to
say I'd support Bernie if he's the
nominee the
first votes are gonna be cast in a few
days so what are we the 22nd the first
votes will be cast in you know but a
couple weeks or whatever it it's very
easy to say I will support the eventual
Democratic nominee the fact that Hillary
Clinton didn't say that is pathetic so
when I say I still believe the most
likely scenario is a Biden nomination
and a loss to trump in November this
type of garbage will guarantee it right
ignorant Trumpets who love the guy is
part of it there are many parts of it
but this is what I committed not to
participate in when we first covered the
primary and we first covered the
candidates that were running and and
also the headlines about what Hillary
said her totally misleading and out of
context the headlines say Hillary says
nobody likes Bernie it suggests she's
talking about people like just random
people she's talking about senators and
legislators she may be right she may be
wrong from what I've heard she's
probably right but it's so relevant it's
irrelevant to whether Bernie has the
right ideas for making the country
better it's irrelevant to whether Bernie
is better than Trump and the fact that
Hillary Clinton is adding idiocy to
idiocy saying nobody likes Bernie okay
that that it even if it's true it's
probably a misstep strategically but
then when she's asked but will you vote
for him will you support him if he's the
nominee and she says it's too early to
talk about that this is how we guarantee
that Donald Trump is reelected in
November I'm not going to participate in
it okay I'm a progressive I'm going to
support a progressive I'm going to
support the eventual Democratic nominee
with the goal of removing Trump and
starting to wake up from the nightmare
that has been the first and hopefully
only term of President Donald Trump let
me know what you think we'll be talking
about this on our Instagram page follow
the david pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show while you're there
follow me at David Pakman as well I know
that the David Pakman show audience is
full of curious and creative people who
love learning new things and bettering
themselves and that's why I'm so excited
to tell you about one of our sponsors
Skillshare the vibrant online learning
community
that offers thousands of classes on
almost any topic you can imagine and
you'll get full access to the entire
library of classes for two entire months
free when you go to david pakman.com
slash skill all of the classes are
taught by experts in their fields
they've got classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
bookkeeping marketing personal
productivity doesn't even scratch the
surface I recently took a class about
photography if anybody follows me on
instagram you know that my photography
skills leave much to be desired and it
was great I got so much out of it and
hopefully you will see the fruits of me
taking that class reflected in my
Instagram pictures sooner than later
they have classes for every skill level
whether you're wanting to get better at
something you already have experience
with you want to learn something totally
new to you you set your own pace classes
are usually less than an hour long
they're divided up into bite-size
segments so you can easily fit them into
your schedule make 2020 a year where you
explore new skills deep in existing
passions get lost in creativity
Skillshare really makes it easier than
ever
Skillshare memberships are less than ten
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll